[Music]
I've got plenty to be thankful for
I need too small I buy them all at the 5
and 10 cents store oh my God
[Music]
I used to love this town
until what happened that night
tomorrow's Thanksgiving and I'm tired of
pretending like everything is normal and
it's not I want things to go back to
normal too
show some enthusiasm Thanksgiving is an
institution here
[Applause]
someone's up for Revenge instead of
turning it into a sick holiday game
this is weird we're all tagged and our
names are at the table but why us
the longer this goes the more Twisted it
gets every weapon he's using is straight
off a Thanksgiving table I don't want to
spend my life looking over my shoulders
we need to stop him
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
it is going to be a very Happy
Thanksgiving
let's see
[Music]
thank you